PROFESSOR: So case A--
weak Zeeman effect.
So what are our states here?
We discovered that and we know
those are the coupled basis
states.
And the states of H0
tilde eigenstates--
they are approximate
eigenstates--
are the states n, l, j, mj.
And the energies were
energies dependent on n and j.
So the 1S 1/2, 2S 1/2,
2P 1/2, and 2P 3/2.
Roughly, to remind
you of what happened,
the original states
were shifted,
and we used the j
quantum number in here.
And those are our multiplets.
Those are our multiplets.
And we have a lot of
degeneracy as usual.
So this is degeneracy
here and degeneracy here
because a multiplet
P 3/2 is j equal 3/2.
And that's four states.
Here you have two
states, and here you
have two states as well.
So quite a bit of states
that are degenerate.
So in principle, when we
do the Zeeman splitting,
we may have to consider the
full matrix n, l, j, mj, delta H
Zeeman, nl prime j m prime j.
So what are our degeneracies?
Our degeneracies are when
you have a given value of j.
So a degenerate subspace
can have different l's--
for example, here--
but the same j,
and therefore different mj's.
Or within a given j multiplet,
it might have different mj's.
So this is the scope
of the degeneracy.
And in principle, we may have to
diagonalize a matrix like that
by looking at the
degenerate spaces.
If you're doing
the level two, you
would have to discuss
these four states here.
You would have to discuss
this other four states.
Happily, we don't
have to do that much
because, as usual, delta H
Zeeman is proportional to l z
plus 2Sz.
And this commutes with l
squared with delta H Zeeman.
l squared commutes
with any l operator.
It certainly commutes
with any S operator.
They don't even
talk to each other.
And therefore, l
squared commutes
with l Zeeman, which
means that when
l is different from l prime,
this matrix element has
to vanish.
This is our remark from
perturbation theory long,
long ago.
You have another
operator for which
the states have different
eigenvalues, commutes
with your perturbation.
The matrix element
of the perturbation
must vanish between
those states.
So we don't have
eigenstates like that.
And when l is equal
to l prime already--
so we focus on l
equals to l prime--
we only need to worry
within multiplets.
So you have n, l, j, mj, delta H
Zeeman now, and l, j, mj prime.
It's an issue of mj prime now.
But Zeeman thing
commutes with Jz.
Jz commutes with delta H Zeeman.
Jz is Lz plus Sz,
and z components
in angular momentum--
two identical components
always commute, of course.
So Jz commutes with
delta H Zeeman.
So this thing will vanish
unless m is equal to m prime.
And that's great
because you're back
to nondegenerate
perturbation theory.
The whole matrix,
this Zeeman thing
could have turned out to
be complicated matrices.
No.
It's perfectly
diagonal in this basis.
There's nothing to
worry about here,
except that it's still not easy
to compute, as we will see.
So what do we need to compute?
We'll have the first
order corrections
due to Zeeman on the n,
l, j, mj basis is equal--
well, the Zeeman Hamiltonian
had an e over 2mc.
So let's put it there.
e.
Let's put the B close to the e.
2mc.
And now we have to do n l
j mj Lz plus 2Sz n l j mj.
Perfectly diagonal.
And that's nondegenerate
perturbation theory.
It's going to give us
all the energies we want.
All the splittings we want.
So basically what's going to
happen, as you can see here,
is that the things down mix.
Everything is there.
Honestly, these two
levels are going to split.
These two levels
are going to split.
These four levels
Everything is going
to split here.
The remarkable thing
of this formula,
and it's going to keep us busy
for about 10, 15 more minutes,
is that this thing, this matrix
element, is proportional to mj.
So the states split proportional
to the m quantum number.
The state with the m equal 3/2
will split three times as much
as the state with m equal 1/2.
And that's not obvious here.
It's a remarkable
result. It's part
of what's called the
Wigner-Eckart theorem,
something that you study in
graduate quantum mechanics.
But we're going to see a bit
of it, the beginning of it,
in this computation.
And it's a fairly
remarkable result.
So the remarkable result here--
remarkable-- is
that E [INAUDIBLE]
are proportional to mj.
And that defines
a linear splitting
because it's linearly
proportional to the magnitude
of the magnetic field and
divides the states nicely.
So we want to understand
this matrix element.
And there's a little
thing we can do.
Notice that Lz plus 2Sz
is equal to Jz plus Sz.
You can take one of the
Sz's and complete Jz,
and you're left with that.
So the matrix element n l j m
Lz plus 2Sz n l j mj is equal--
if you have a Jz, that gives
you just something proportional
to Hmj plus n l
j mj Sz n l j mj.
So OK.
A little bit of
the mystery maybe
seems to you at least
consistent here.
I said this matrix element turns
out to be proportional to mj.
And certainly,
this piece, having
to do with the J component
here, is proportional to mj.
The mystery that remains
is why this matrix element
would be proportional to mj.